this is kind of what
empathy is in open-mindedness is try to
um
consider that the set of concepts that
your your brain has constructed
through which you are now perceiving the
world is
not painting the full picture i mean
this is now true for basically ever
it doesn't have to be men and women it
could be basically the prism through
which would perceive actually the
political discourse right
absolutely so so here's what i would say
um the
you know there are people who scientists
who will talk to you about
cognitive empathy and emotional empathy
and i
i prefer to think of it
i think the evidence is more consistent
with what i'm about to say which is that
your brain is um always making
predictions
using your your own past experience and
what you've learned
from you know books and movies and other
people telling you about their
experiences and so on
and if your brain cannot make a concept
to make sense of those anticipate what
those sense data are
and make sense of them you will be
experientially blind
so you know when i'm giving lectures to
people i'll show them like a blobby
black and white image
and they're experientially blind to the
image
they can't see anything in it and then i
show them a photograph and then i show
them the image again
the blobby image and then they see
actually an object in it but the art but
the image
is the same it's there they're actually
adding their predictions now are
adding right or anything for example
anybody who's
learned a language uh
a second language after their first
language
also has this experience of um
things that initially sound like sounds
that they can't quite make sense of
eventually come
to make they eventually come to make
sense of them and in fact there are
really cool examples
of people who are like born blind
because they have cataracts
or they have corneal damage so that
no light is reaching
the brain and then they have an
operation
and then light reaches the brain and
they can't see
for days and weeks and sometimes
years they have they are experientially
blind to certain things
so what happens with empathy right is
that your brain
is making a prediction and if it doesn't
if it doesn't have the capacity
to um
make it doesn't if you don't share if
you're not similar
remember you mean you know categories
are
instances which are similar in some way
if you are
not similar enough to that person you
will have a hard time making a
prediction about what they feel
you will be experientially blind to what
they feel
in the united states children
of color are under prescribed medicine
by their physicians this
is been documented
it's not that the physicians
are racist necessarily
but they might be experientially blind
the same thing is true of male
physicians with female patients
i could tell you some hair-raising
stories
really that where people die as a
consequence
of a physician making the wrong
inference the wrong prediction because
of being experientially blind
so we are
you know empathy is not um it's not
magic
it's we make inferences about each other
about what each other's feeling and
thinking
in this culture more than there are some
cultures where
you know people have what's called
opacity of mind where they
will make a prediction about someone
else's actions but they're not inferring
anything about the internal state of
that person
but in our culture we're constantly
making inferences
what is this person thinking what is and
we're not doing it necessarily
consciously but it's doing it really
automatically using our
predictions what we know and
if you expose yourself to
information which is very different from
somebody else i mean
really what we have is we have different
cultures in this
in this country right now that are there
are a number of reasons
for this i mean part of it is i don't
know if you saw the
social dilemma the the netflix um uh
part about it yeah it's a great it's
really great
um documentary and uh about what social
networks are doing to our society
yeah yeah but you know nothing
no phenomenon has a a simple single
cause
there are multiple small causes which
all add up to a perfect storm that's
that's just you know how most things
work
and so the fact that machine learning
algorithms are serving people
up information on social media that is
consistent with what they've already
viewed
and making you know um
is part of the reason that you have
these silos but it's not the only reason
why you have these silos i think there
are other
there are other things afoot that uh
enhance um people's inability to
even have a decent conversation yeah i
mean okay so
so many things you said are just
brilliant so the experiment
experiential blindness but also from my
perspective
like i i preach and i try to practice
empathy a lot and something about the
way you've explained it
makes me almost see it as a kind of
exercise that we should all do like to
train
like to add experiences to the brain to
expand this capacity
to predict more effectively absolutely
so like what
like what i do is kind of like a method
acting thing which is
i imagine what the life of a person is
like
you know just think i mean this is
something you see with black lives
matter
and uh police officers it feels like
they're both
uh not both but i have because martial
arts and so on i have a lot of friends
who are cops
they don't necessarily
um have empathy or visualize the
experience of the other
certainly currently unfortunately people
aren't doing that with police officers
they're not imagining they're not
empathizing
or putting themselves in the shoes of a
police officer to realize how difficult
that job is
how dangerous it is how difficult it is
to maintain calm
and under so much uncertainty all those
kind of things you know but there's more
there's even that's all that's true but
i think that there's even more
there's even more to be said there i
mean like from a predicting brain
standpoint
there's even more that can be said there
so i don't know if you want to go down
that path or you can
strip on empathy but i will also say
that
one of the things that i was most
gratified by i
still am receiving you know it's been
three
more than three and a half years since
how emotions were made came out and i'm
still receiving
daily emails from people right so that's
gratifying but one of the
most gratifying emails i received was
from police officer
in texas who told me that he thought
that how motions are made
contained information that
would be really helpful to
resolving some of these difficulties
and he hadn't even read my op-ed piece
about when is a gun not a gun and you
know like using
the what we know about the science of
perception from predict from a
prediction
standpoint like the brain is a predictor
to understand
a little differently what might be
happening in these circumstances
so there's there's a real what's hard
about it's hard to talk about because
everyone gets mad at you when you talk
about this like
you know and um there is a way to
understand this which has profound
empathy
for the suffering of
people of color and that
definitely is in line with black lives
matter at the same time
as understanding the really difficult
situation
that police officers find themselves in
and i'm not talking about this bad apple
or that bad apple i'm not talking about
police officers who are necessarily
shooting people in the back as they run
away
i'm talking about the cases of really
good
well-meaning cops who
have the kind of predicting brain that
everybody else has
they're in a really difficult situation
that i think both they and
the people who are harmed
don't realize like they just the the way
that these situations are constructed i
think it's just
there's a lot to be said there i guess
is what i want is there something we can
try to say
in a sense like what i'm from the
perspective of the predictive brain
which is a
fascinating perspective uh to take on
this
you know the all the protests that are
going on
there seems to be a concept of a police
officer being built
no i think that police i think that
concept is there
but it's it's gaining strength so it's
being re-um
i mean yeah it is sure it is sure but i
think
yeah for sure i think that that's right
i think that there's um
there's a shift in the
stereotype of what i would say is a
stereotype there's a stereotype of
of uh black man in this country that's
always
in movies and television not always but
like largely
um uh that many people watch
i mean you know you think you're
watching a 10 o'clock drama
and all you're doing is like kicking
back and relaxing but actually
you're having certain predictions
reinforced
and others not and what's happening
what's happening now with police
is the same thing um that there are
certain stereotypes of a police officer
that are being abandoned and other
stereotypes that are being reinforced
by by what you see happening
all i'll say is that if you remember i
mean there's a lot to say about this
really that you know
regardless of whether it makes people
mad or not i mean i just i
the science is what it is um
just remember what i said the brain
is makes predictions about internal
changes in the body first and then motor
it starts to prepare motor action
and then it makes a prediction about
what you will see
and hear and feel based on those actions
okay so
it's also the case that we didn't talk
about is that
sensory sampling like your brain's
ability to sample what's out there
is yoked to your heart rate it's yoke to
your heartbeats
there are certain phases of the
heartbeat where it's easier for you to
see
what's happening in the world than in
others
and so if your heart rate goes through
the roof
you will be less like you will be more
likely to just go with your prediction
and not correct based on what you
what's out there because you're actually
literally not seeing as well
or you will see things that aren't there
basically
is there something that we could say in
by way of advice
for when this episode is released in the
in the chaos of uh emotion sorry i don't
know about a term
that's just flying around on social
media what's um
well i actually think it is it is
emotion in the following sense
you know and it sounds a little bit like
it sounds a little bit like
artificial when i and the way i'm about
to say it but i really think that this
is what's happening
you know one thing we haven't talked
about is
you know brains evolved didn't evolve
for you to see they didn't evolve for
you to hear
they didn't evolve for you to feel they
evolved to control your body
that's why you have a brain you have a
brain so they control your body
and the metaphor the there's a the
scientific term for
predictively controlling your body is
allostasis your brain is making
um is attempting to it's tempting to
anticipate the needs of your body and
meet those needs before they arise so
that you can act
as you need to act and
the metaphor that i use is a body budget
you know your brain is running a budget
for your body
it's not budgeting money it's budgeting
glucose and salt and water
and instead of having you know one or
two bank accounts it has
gazillions there are all these systems
in your body that have to be kept in
balance
and it's monitoring very closely
it's making predictions about like when
is it good to spend and when is it good
to save and what would be a good
investment and am i going to get a
return on my investment
whenever people talk about reward or
reward prediction error or anything to
do with reward
their or punishment they're talking
about
the body budget they're talking about
your brain's predictions about whether
or not there will be a deposit
or withdrawal so
when you when your brain is running a
deficit in your body budgets you have
some kind of metabolic imbalance
you experience that as discomfort
you experience that as distress when
your brain
when things are chaotic you can't
predict
what's going to happen next so i have
this
absolutely brilliant scientist working
in my lab
his name is um jordan uh tario and he's
published this really terrific paper on
um a sense of should like why do we have
social rules why do we um
you know uh adhere to social norms
it's because if i make myself
predictable to you
then you are predictable to me and if
you're predictable to me
that's good because that that is less
metabolically expensive for me
novelty or unpredictability at the
extreme
is expensive and if it goes on for long
enough
what happens is first of all you will
feel really jittery and antsy
which we describe as anxiety
it isn't necessarily anxiety it could be
just
something is not predictable and you are
experiencing arousal because
the chemicals that help you learn
increase
your feeling of arousal basically but if
it goes on for long enough
you will become depleted and you will
start to feel
really really really distressed so what
we have
is a culture full of people right now
who are their body budgets are just
decimated
and there's a tremendous amount of
uncertainty
when you talk about it as depression
anxiety it makes
you think that it's not about your
metabolism that it's not about your body
budgeting
that it's not about getting enough sleep
or about eating
well or about making sure that you have
social connections
um it's you know it's you think that
it's something separate from that but
depression anxiety are just a way of
being in the world
they're a way of being in the world when
things aren't quite right with your
predictions
that's such a deep way of thinking like
the the brain is
uh maintaining homeostasis
it's actually allostational stasis i'm
sorry uh
and it's it's constantly making
predictions
and metabolically speaking it's very
costly to make novel
like constantly be learning to making
adjustments
and over time there's you know there's
uh
cost to be paid uh if you're just yeah
in
in in a place of chaos where there's
constant need for adjusting and learning
and
experience novel things and so part of
the problem here
there are a couple of things like i said
you know it's a perfect storm there
isn't a single cause
right there are multiple cause multiple
things that combine together it's a
complex
it's a complex system multiple things
part of it is that um people are
they're they're metabolically encumbered
and they're distressed and in order to
try to
have empathy for someone who is very
much unlike you
you have to forage for information you
you have to explore
information that is novel to you
and unexpected and that's expensive
and at a time when people feel what do
you do when you
are running a deficit in your bank
account you stop spending
what does it mean for a brain to stop
spending
a brain stops moving very much stops
moving the body
and it stops learning it just goes with
its internal model
brilliantly put yep so
empathy requires to have empathy for
someone who is
unlike you yeah requires
learning and practice you're foraging
for information
i mean it is something i talk about in
my in the book in seven and a half
lessons about the brain i think it's
really important it's hard
but it's hard i think it's you know it
it's hard for people to have
to be curious about views that are
unlike their own um
when um when they feel so encumbered
and i'll just tell you i had this
epiphany really
um i was listening to robert reich's um
the system he was talking about
oligarchy versus democracy
so oligarchy is where very wealthy
people like extremely wealthy people
um shift power
so that they become even more wealthy
and even more insulated and
from the you know the pressures of the
common person
um it's actually the kind of system
that leads to the collapse of
civilizations if you believe jared
diamond
just say that but anyways i'm listening
to this and i'm listening to him
describe
in fairly decent detail
how the ceos of these companies
there's been a shift in what it means to
be a ceo and not not being no longer
being a steward
of the community and so on but like in
the 1980s it sort of shifted to this
other model of being like an oligarch
and
he's talking about how you know it used
to be the case that
um that ceos uh
made like 20 times uh what their
um their employees made and now they
make about 300 times
on average whether employees made so
where did that money come from
it came from the pockets of the
employees
and they don't they don't know about it
right no one knows about it they just
know
they can't feed their children they
can't pay for health care
they can't take care of their family and
they worry about what's going to happen
to their
they you know they're living like you
know months a month basically
any one big bill could completely you
know put them out on the street
so there are a huge number of people
living like this so
all they what their experience they
don't know why they're experiencing it
so it's
and then someone comes along and gives
them a narrative
yeah well somebody else butted in line
in front of you
and that's why you're this way
that's why you experience what you're
experiencing i just for a minute
i was thinking i had deep
empathy for people who have beliefs
that are really really really
different from mine but
i was trying really hard to see it
through their eyes
and did it cost me something
metabolically
i'm sure i'm sure but you add something
in the gas tank
well i in order to allocate that i mean
well that's the question is like where
did you
you what resources did your brain draw
on in order to actually make that effort
well i'll tell you something honestly
lex i don't have that much in the gas
tank right now
[Laughter]
right so uh i i am surfing
the stress that you know stress is just
what is stress stress is your brain is
preparing for a big metabolic outlay and
it just keeps preparing and preparing
and preparing and preparing
you as a professor you as a human both
right it's a for me this is a moment of
existential
crisis as much as anybody else democracy
all of these things
so in many of my roles
so i guess what i'm trying to say is
that um
i get up every morning and i exercise i
run
i row i lift weights right you exercise
in the middle of the day
i saw your like yeah you know daily
thing yeah
i hate it actually you love it right you
get it no i hate it i
hate it but i do it religiously
yeah why because it's a really good
investment
it's an expenditure that is a really
good investment
and so
when i was exercising i was listening to
the book and when i realized the
insights that i was sort of like
playing around with like is this does
this make sense does this make sense
i didn't immediately plunge into it i
basically
wrote some stuff down i set it aside and
then i
did what i prepared myself to make an
expenditure
i don't know what you do before you
exercise i always have
a protein shake always have a protein
shake because i need to
fuel up before i make this really big
expenditure and so
i did the same thing i didn't have a
protein drink but i
um but i i did the same thing and
fueling up can mean lots of different
things it can mean talking to a friend
about it it can mean
um you know it can it can mean get
making sure you get a good night's sleep
before you do it it can mean
lots of different things but i guess i
i think we have to
do these things i uh yeah that
this i'm gonna re-listen to this
conversation several times this is
brilliant uh
but i do i do think about
you know i've encountered so many people
that can't possibly imagine that a good
human being can vote for donald trump
and i've also encountered people
that can't imagine that an intelligent
person can possibly vote
for democrat and
i i look at both these people many of
whom are friends
and let's just say
after this conversation i can see as
they're predicting brains not willing to
invest
the resources to empathize with the
other side and i think
you have to in order to be able to like
to see the obvious common humanity in us
i don't know what the system is that's
creating this division
we can put it like you said it's a
perfect storm it might be the social
media
might be i don't know what the hell i
think it's a bunch of things i think
it's
just there's an economic system which is
disadvantaging
large numbers of people there's a
use of social media like if you you know
if i
had to orchestrate or architect a system
that would screw up a human body budget
it would be the one
that we live in you know we don't sleep
enough we eat
pseudo food basically um we are on
social media
too much which is full of ambiguity
which is really hard for
a human nervous system right really
really hard like
ambiguity with no context to predict it
i mean it's like
really and then you know there are the
economic concerns that
affect large swaths of people in this
country i mean it's really
you i'm not saying everything is
reducible to
metabolism not everything is reducible
to metabolism but
there if you combine all these things
together
it's helpful to think of it that way
then somehow it's also
somehow reduces the entirety of the
human experience the same kind of
obvious logic like we should exercise
every day in the same kind of way
we should uh we should empathize every
day
yeah you know there are these really
wonderful wonderful programs for
um for teens and um sometimes also for
parents of
people who've lost children in in wars
and in conflicts in political conflicts
where they go to a bucolic setting and
they talk to each other about their
experiences
and um miraculous things happen
you know so um
you know it's easy to uh
it's easy to sort of shrug this stuff
off as
kind of pollyanna-ish you know like
what's this really going to do but
um you have to think about
when my daughter went to college i i
gave her advice i said
uh try to
be around people who let you be the kind
of person you want to be
you were back to free will you have a
choice
you have a choice it might seem like a
really hard choice it might seem like a
unimaginably difficult choice do you
have a choice
do you want to be somebody who um
is wrapped in in fury and agony
or do you want to be somebody who
extends
uh a little empathy to somebody else and
in the process maybe learn something
curiosity is the thing that it protects
you
curiosity is the thing it's curative
curiosity
on social media the thing i recommend to
people
at least that's the way i've been
approaching social media i i don't
it doesn't seem to be the common
approach but i basically
uh give love to people who seem to
also give love to others so it's the
same similar concept of
surrounding by yourself by the people
you want to become
and i ignore sometimes block but just
ignore
i don't i don't add aggression to people
who
are just constantly full of aggression
and negativity and toxicity
there's a certain desire when somebody
says something mean
to to um to say something
to you know say why or try to alleviate
the meanness and so on
but what you're doing essentially is
you're and you're you're now surrounding
yourself by that
group of folks that have that negativity
so even just the conversation
so i you know i i think it's just so
powerful to uh to put yourself amongst
people
who are yeah who whose basic mode of
interaction is kindness
because uh i mean i don't know what it
is but maybe
i'm just it's the way i'm built is that
to me is energizing for the gas tank
of that that i can pull to for sure when
i start reading
the rise and fall of the third reich and
start thinking about
nazi germany i can empathize with
everybody involved i can start to think
make these difficult uh like thinking
that's required to understand
our little planet earth well there is
research
to back up what you said there's
research that's consistent with your
intuition there
you know that there's research that
shows that
being kind to other people doing
something nice for someone else
is like making a deposit to some extent
you know because i think um
[Music]
making a deposit not only in their body
budgets but also in yours
like people feel good when they do good
things for other people
you know we are social animals we
regulate each other's nervous systems
for better and for worse right the best
thing
for a human nervous system is another
human
and the worst thing for a human nervous
system is another human
so you decide do you want to be somebody
who makes people feel
who who who makes people feel better
or do you want to be somebody who causes
people pain
and we are more responsible
for one another than we might like
or than we might want but remember what
we said about social reality
you know social reality so you you
you know there are lots of different
cultural
uh norms about uh you know independence
or
or you know collective you know nature
of people
but the fact is we have socially
dependent nervous systems
we evolve that way as a species and in
this country
we prize individual rights and freedoms
and that is a dilemma that we have to
grapple with and we have to do it in a
way if we're going to be productive
about it we have to do it in a way
that
requires engaging with each other and
which is what i understand
the you know the founding members of
this country
uh intended
you